a matter that there's a volcano it
matters it matters a lot because that's
75 percent of the identity of this place
the volcano is present the volcanoes
breathing the the volcano really is
actually a living creature it's a bit of
a romantic representation maybe although
then geology is all that does have a
romantic component to it the major
catastrophe here a Stromboli it's a
major landslide which can trigger a
tsunami there are no volcanologist who
just sit on their desk and process data
you have first to collect data and to
collect data you have to climb on top of
a volcano there is no other solution
it's something amazing you just climbed
to the summit is a strong crime is a
strong hike and when you reach the
summit you you have a very beautiful
landscape and you really can feel the
explosions after almost 13 years of very
careful the physical monitoring of the
activity I would say that this region
c'est L'Amour second domain Tricia molto
Sulu more Adela persona condo mentality
Vita presenting a noventa nervosa una
cosa communal effort zone because the
volcano is a living creatures and how it
has also to be very much respected
sometimes we forget that we are living
on top of this you know volcano and a
lot of people reckon that this is a big
big bomb but you know this trouble
wherever you go and you can die in any
place so if somebody one day is gonna
explode it I'm gonna die okay this is
the life this the way it goes
you
[Music]